[Music]
good evening tonight roughly 60 000
vaccines have been administered in
southern nevada so far
thank you for joining us at five i'm
brian loftis while there is a push to
get vaccines out
the health district says they are
closing the county's largest site
for a few days joe mohler live at
cashman center with more on that and a
reminder that people
do need to have appointments joe
[Music]
that is right appointments are needed in
the health district is pushing for that
well this facility has been open for a
little more than a week and so far 14
000 doses have been administered here
alone now take a look this uh doors
closed here not too long ago there's
some
uh setup outside still where people are
waiting in line thousands come here
every day but people who are
waiting for their appointment say
they're noticing some others who don't
have appointments
showing up trying to get a shot roughly
2 000 vaccines are ministered
here a day people have to make an
appointment online when you show up you
must wait in a line that could take up
to two hours while there are complaints
of people showing up without
appointments
the health district tells me they are
working to make sure everyone who is
here is supposed to be here
and have an appointment if you don't she
will be asked to leave i spoke to wayne
smith who got his vaccine today
i saw four people trying to get in line
without appointments and they said sorry
i'm glad they turned them away because i
heard the other day they were letting
anybody in
state officials are optimistic now as
the race is on to get as many people
vaccinated as possible during today's
open 19 statewide mitigation meeting
officials say they believe we are
finished with the majority of the spike
from holiday related cases
hospitalizations are down in northern
nevada but not much of a change here in
southern nevada
hospital staffing shortages are starting
to stabilize but hospitalizations remain
higher than
expected now they say they won't see
much of an impact from the vaccine on
the current curve
for quite some time now back out here
live we're taking another live look at
cashman center this evening
the facility here will be closed
tomorrow uh through this weekend and
that is because the southern nevada
health district wants to make
improvements to the process in which
people come here
and go through uh go through the line
and another point they mentioned today
when i did get information from them is
that when people do show up without an
appointment it actually slows that
process down for those who are in line
with an appointment again
the appointment's gonna take one to two
hours here so they're trying to speed
this process up
as fast as they can reporting live here
cashman sign up this evening joe moeller
8 news now